we welcomed Finland as our newest member
and Minister hobby store took up Finance
seat among NATO allies
allies also agree that Sweden should
become an ally as quickly as possible
we addressed many important topics over
the past two years including how to
strengthen our political and practical
support for Ukraine
we met yesterday in the NATO Ukraine
commission with foreign minister coleba
we agree and that our continued mental
support for Ukraine is essential I
welcome the new commitments made by
allies and I expect more
we also addressed our longer term
support we do not know when this war
will end but when it does we must ensure
that President Putin cannot continue
to chip away at European security
so we must enable Ukraine to deter and
defend against future aggression
this includes strengthening Ukraine's
armed forces and arrangements for
Ukraine's security
we agreed to start work on developing a
strategic multi-air assistance program
for Ukraine
clear demonstration that our support
will continue for a long haul
to increase Ukraine's interoperability
with NATO and to bring it up to Nato
standards
this will assist Ukraine on its path to
euro-atlantic integration because
Ukraine's future is in the euro-atlantic
family
NATO allies are committed to giving
Ukraine what it needs to Prevail as a
sovereign independent nation in Europe
and to achieve a just and durable peace
at the same time we will continue to
support our partners facing pressure
from Russia including Moldova Georgia
and Boston
we also discussed the threats and
challenges challenges in the Middle East
and North Africa including instability
terrorism and the growing activities of
Russia and China
we will continue to work closely with
our partners including Mauritania
antonesia to help them build up their
defense institutions and stabilize their
countries
to keep our people safe in a more
dangerous world it is essential that we
invest more in our defense
so today I mean this is also addressed
progress on defense spending
at the Village Summit I expect allies to
agree and ambitious a new defense
investment pledge with two percent of
GDP as a floor not the ceiling
for our final session a NATO's Asia
Pacific Partners Australia Japan New
Zealand and Republic of Korea joined us
together with the European Union
we discussed the global consequences of
Russia's war against Ukraine this war is
not only an attack on Ukraine but on the
international rules-based order that
preserves peace and stability
if President Putin wins in Ukraine it
will send a dangerous message to
authoritarian leaders around the world
that they can achieve their goals
through Brute Force
so support Ukraine remains critical and
it is in our shared security interest
we also discussed China's growing
alignment with Russia
China refuses to condemn Russia's
aggression it echoes Russian propaganda
and it props UPS Russia's economy
China and Russia are also stepping off
the joint military activities in the
india-pacific region
allies have been cleared that any
provision of little Aid by China to
Russia would be a historic mistake with
profound implications
at a time when Beijing and Moscow are
pushing back against the rules based in
Nash order it is even more important
that we continue to stand together as
NATO allies and with like-minded
partners
and with that I'm ready to take your
questions
we'll start with the BBC in the third
round
thank you very much Secretary General
can I ask you you said that you're
talking about a new ambitious spending
Target of two percent but two percent is
already the spending Target of NATO is
there any way at Vilnius you will
actually and you've said before that you
know it's a it's a flaw not a ceiling so
I'm I'm not confident that is a new
spending Target if you can explain to me
why it is a new spending Target wouldn't
it be more honest to say you know a new
figure is a new spending Target like say
240.5 percent do you think there's a
possibility that might happen
and then and then you've clearly issued
a warning to China about providing
lethal Aid to Russia is there any
evidence among allies
that China is doing that thank you very
much
um
first on two percent you're right that
when NATO leaders met in 2014
uh in the United Kingdom in Wales we
agreed a defense investment pledge where
we also used to present US GDP as the
guideline but then we refer to two
percent as something we should strive
towards move towards so it has been
interpreted by many allies as something
that is more like is a ceiling something
we should move towards which is actually
the language you use in that statement
or in that touch agreed in 2014.
um
since then actually allies have come a
long way because since then all allies
have increased defense spending and uh
and and this is significant because
until 2014 uh the majority of NATO
allies across Europe and Canada actually
were reducing defense spending every
year so what we manage with the pledge
we made in 2014 was to turn the corner
uh not going down anymore but actually
start to go up and all allies have
increased the defense spending more
allies meet the two percent guideline or
are spending or or at two percent or
above
um uh but many allies are still below
and some of them also then refer to all
this is uh something we should strive
towards not not a kind of requirement
so that's uh what I'm uh mean that's
that that's my message when I speak
about the stronger commitment is to have
much stronger language that this is not
some kind of ambitious uh goal in in
this the future that we should strive
towards it is something that we should
be strongly committed to and as a two
percent as a minimum not as as the
ceiling so I actually think it will make
a difference if not only I say that two
percent should be a minimum but at all
uh allies agree that that two percent
should be a minimum uh a floor
um the most important thing is of course
what allies do and I'm quite encouraged
because I also now see that several of
those allies haven't been not able to
reach two percent uh like Germany like
the Netherlands and others Denmark and
many others uh they are they are now
very committed to increasing defense
spending and and and to reach two
percent uh uh other soon
and that's because the war in Ukraine
which has made it even more obvious that
we need to invest more in defense when
it comes to
to China of course we are monitoring
very closely what China does
any provision of a little Aid to uh to
Russia from uh from China will be a big
mistake well with profound consequences
um uh so far we have not been able to
confirm any provision of elite laid but
this is something we we follow very
closely and we also communicate very
clearly that this will be a big mistake
then what we do know is that China has
not been able to condemn the brutal
invasion of Ukraine we also know that
that China and Russia are coming closer
and closer they signed just weeks before
the invasion a partnership agreement
where they State clearly that the
partnership between Russia and China is
without any limits a partnership with no
limits uh and then we of of course also
know that China is propping up Russia's
economy so this is of course of concern
and we need to be clear on these issues
in our engagement with China
The Economist
Anton LaGuardia of The Economist
um I was wondering whether you could be
more precise in some of the wording that
you use you say that Ukraine's Futures
in the euro-atlantic family does that
mean that NATO's future is in NATO and
when uh what does the multi-annual
um uh program for Ukraine to help
integrate it further I mean how is that
different from what is being done today
to help Ukraine defend itself and last
on China what do you actually mean by
saying is a big mistake with um uh with
profound consequences if China were to
provide lethalated what would it what
would the consequences be thank you
first on on NATO and Ukraine
NATO's position is that Ukraine will
become a member of the alliance
and that position not changed
but we know that there are at least two
things you need to address to make that
possible
um one is that we need to ensure that
Ukraine prevails as a sovereign in the
plantation of course any meaningful
discussion about Ukraine as a member of
the alliance uh has to be based on that
Ukraine is a democratic independent
nation in uh in Europe and that's
exactly what is now challenged or
threatened by the uh brutal Russian
invasion so the first step the basic
requirement is to provide a military
support to Ukraine so so President Putin
doesn't win uh his war of aggression the
second thing we need to address is that
when this war ends and Ukraine prevails
then of course we need to ensure that we
have the highest level of
interoperability that that that uh
Russia that that Ukraine is able to move
from from soviet-era standards doctrines
ways of operating their Armed Forces
this transition has started but we need
more and we need to implement it quicker
and therefore the difference between the
current
uh support that they donate allies is
providing to Ukraine is that that's
that's the immediate needs uh allies are
providing of course weapons uh uh
Military Support uh NATO is also
providing a lot of non-lethal support
but that's to address the immediate
needs to help Ukraine now this program
is more long-term perspective that is
about you know building the institutions
helping with the transition the
interoperability the standards the
doctrines all of these things that we
need to have in place
also to move towards uh membership so
that's in a way the difference uh then
the second question will China well
other consequences I I think I will only
lean pencil to say that it has been made
clear by several allies also the biggest
Ally that there will be severe
consequences uh and I think there's no
reason to go into details but but China
knows that will be severe consequences
if they start to provide a little Aid to
um to uh to Ukraine to to to Russia
sorry
okay we'll go to the um cave independent
uh
Independence uh how high do you assess
is the likelihood that perilous would
become a direct participant of Russia's
war against Ukraine and what do you
think would encourage the rukashenko
regime to make this move and my second
question is how have the NATO always
given enough weapons for Ukraine to
launch a counter offensive in the
nearest weeks and how many Advanced
Western tanks can Ukraine expect to
receive from later to the end of the
year thank you
uh well the Allies are delivering uh uh
uh uh unprecedented Military Support to
Ukraine we have also stepped up our
Support over the last weeks and months
and also with uh armored vehicles uh
battle tanks but not only battle tanks
but also infantry fighting vehicles uh
uh armored personnel carriers and a lot
of support meaning for instance fuel
trucks uh heavy systems to uh to remind
mine to to remove minefields and to
enable the ukrainians to cross uh all
the the defense barriers that the
Russians have built up over the last
months so so uh so so this is not only
about the the battle tanks but all the
support they need to be able to function
and operate as they should not only for
a few days but for weeks and therefore
this is also about
sustainment meaning providing the fuel
diminishing the spare parts the
maintenance capacity that need to follow
and support these these these efforts
um
there is there's a in totality there is
a high number I don't have the number in
my head now but the Intel is a high
number of uh of Battle Tanks some of
them are older battle tanks some of them
are Soviet era battle tanks but many of
them are also now modern NATO standard
battle tanks the UK has delivered a
challenger many NATO allies have
delivered a leopard too
and then the US is also now in the
process of delivering Abrahams this
comes on top on of the for instance the
martyrs which is a infantry fighting
Vehicles the Bradleys which is a U.S
infantry fighting vehicles and it is
this totality that provides the
ukrainians with the capabilities they
need to retake land to to further push
back the the Russian Russian
forces it it is for the ukrainians to
make the operational decisions on
exactly how and when our responsibility
is to to help them on Belarus well
Belarus
um has been and continues to be a
platform which Russia uses in its
aggressive actions against the uh
um against uh Ukraine they launched the
part of the invasion from from from
belarusa and they have launched several
airstrikes from others our message to
Belarus is of course that they should
not be directly involved uh and uh and
uh
um we will just continue to provide
Ukraine with the support they need to uh
to fight against aggression uh and uh
and to win this war
okay sidif
thanks
secretary Channel I have a more general
question on China
as The View on China changed are you
ready to change or is NATO ready to
change the Strategic concept towards
China
no the reality is that the Strategic
concept we agreed in Madrid reflects
NATO's also say a new uh uh recognition
of what China means for our security
because I think we need to realize that
NATO has come a long way when it comes
to uh to to China in the Strategic
concept we had until last summer China
was not mentioned with a single word
then in the Strategic concept we agreed
in Madrid in in June laws there
we made important decisions we don't
regard
China is an adversary but we stayed
clearly in the Strategic concept that
China's assertive Behavior
poses a challenge to our interests our
values to our security and this is
reflected in the fact that China is
investing heavily in new modern
capabilities including long-range
nuclear missiles
they are cracking down on Democratic
rights in their own country in Hong Kong
Prosecuting minorities
using social media the internet to to to
to to have surveillance of the
population the way we haven't seen at
that scale anytime before
um they the assertive behavior in the
South China Sea is a challenge for the
countries in the region but there's a
challenge to the international trade the
threats against Taiwan
um and then of course the fact that
China is coming closer to us we see them
in cyberspace we see them trying to
control critical infrastructure and all
of this and also then of course that
they are now working more and more
closely with Russia
we see Russian Chinese joined Naval
patrols uh air patrols we saw a big
emitter exercise outside the coast of
Africa and all of this together has
actually
made it necessary for us to to update
and to develop our policies on on China
that is reflected in the new strategic
concept it is also reflected in the fact
that we are now significantly
strengthening our partnership with our
indo-pacific partners with Australia
with uh with the New Zealand Japan and
South Korea they participated in the
meeting today for the first time ever we
invited the heads of certain government
to participate in our Summit
last summer and I invited the heads of
state and government from Japan New
Zealand South Korea and Australia also
to attend our Summit next summer or this
summer in in Venus so put together this
is a huge effort and let me just add
what we do on resilience on technology
is also a way to respond to the
challenges that China poses to our
security
okay John hop
lady here yeah
nope nope thanks
thanks
to South Korea um Secretary General you
have urged Korea to increase its
military support to Ukraine when you
visited uh Korea last January and
um saying that some countries have
changed their policy to send weapons
directly to Ukraine after the war and
did you raise this among today's
discussion as well and I would like what
was Korea's response if you had and
regarding if I may ask another one
regarding the NATO's non-lethal
assistance package which Japan has
recently pledged did the vice minister
of Korea Express his intention for a
contribution as well today thanks
first of all I think it's for uh Korea
to to to to to to to provide exact
answers uh on their positions and what
they do what what I can say is that uh
we are uh it was a big issue when I
visited Korea in January
um and I've also raised it again and I
welcome the fact that South Korea has
made it clear that they are ramping of
production
um uh and we need to understand that uh
that it helps that South Korea is
ramping up production and delivering uh
also to NATO allies because then we can
replenish our own stocks and South Korea
is a big producer of ammunition
um and the fact that they are now
delivering war and producing more to
replenish the stocks of NATO allies
enable us to continue to deliver to uh
to Ukraine
um so I will what I say
I'll not go into the issue of exactly
how or to whom South Korea should
deliver my main message is that by
providing more uh Aid to uh or not aid
but also the supplies of ammunition to
to NATO allies then enable us to
continue to support Ukraine and our
welcome announcements made from the
South Korea on that
okay right
thank you my question is about migrants
did you talk with Italian foreign
minister tayani about this problem what
can NATO do in that part of the
Mediterranean thank you so much
well in the meeting we have today the
issue of migration was supported the
discussion especially when we addressed
the challenges
emanating from the Middle East and North
Africa and of course what NATO does and
this is also something I've discussed
with the Italian foreign minister with
the Italian Prime Minister several times
is is that we are helping to support the
efforts of individual allies but also of
the European Union and we have a NATO
Naval presence in their GNC to help to
implement the agreement between turkey
and the EU on illegal migration we are
working with Partners in the in the
Middle East and North Africa we have our
presence our training mission in Iraq to
try to address the Ruth courses stable
Iraq a stable Middle East is of course
important also to address the youth
courses of the migrant challenges that
Europe is facing and we are also
stepping up our cooperation and and
support to countries like Tunisia and uh
and Mauritania
um and then of course we are exchanging
information we're helping each other us
as NATO allies but but the the migrant
and Refugee issue is of course something
that has to be addressed in many
different tools and many of them are
outside in the NATO mandate but some of
them are and we are working with
countries Iraq Mauritania and others to
help to distribute causes
I'm wondering whether NATO still
believes that China holds sway over
Russia with regards to the war in
Ukraine especially after Russia
announced plans to station nuclear
weapons in Belarus days after it had
signed a declaration with China saying
countries shouldn't station weapons
abroad thank you
what we know is that Russia is more and
more dependent on China
trade with China
has become even more important for
Russia
not least because of the economic
sanctions and and the consequences of
the war in Ukraine I also believe that
uh the announcement that they will
deploy tactical weapons nuclear weapons
to uh to Belarus just after a sign an
agreement stating the opposite just
shows that these are empty promises uh
and we what we need to to watch close is
actually what Russia is doing uh and um
and that's exactly what NATO allies are
are monitoring closely so far we haven't
seen any changes in the Russian nuclear
posture that requires any changes in our
posture but we remain Vigilant we will
follow closely what they do and we have
increased our presence in eastern part
of the Lions to to remove any room for
misunderstanding miscalculation Moscow
about NATO's Readiness to protect and
defend all allies and we do that not to
provoke a conflict but to prevent the
conflict to to to prevent any military
attack on their dollars okay we'll take
one last question from Politico
um thank you very much Ali from Politico
um Secretary General did ministers
discuss the arrest and continued
Detention of Wall Street Journal
reporter Evan gershkovic and did they
discuss any concrete steps or actions
that they can take to help secure his
immediate release thank you
my
message is that the Wall Street Journal
Journal Journey should be released and
uh and this is about freedom of
of the press and the importance of
journalists to be able to operate and to
ask difficult questions and to do their
work and many other allies have expected
has experienced exactly the same call on
on Russia
thank you very much colleagues this
concludes this press conference thank
you thank you